hello
today I'm going to be talking about a
predictive model to guide monkey box
testing based on clinical presentation
so what is monkeypox
monkeypox is a rare rile disease that is
very similar to smallpox it is
considered an emergency infectious
disease and it's probiotically endemic
to West Africa
symptoms include systemic symptoms such
as fever swollen lymph nodes respiratory
symptoms
penile edema or all lesions solitary
fluid-filled lesions and a rash
the first monkey box case in the United
States was reported on May 8th 2022 in
Boston
by August it had spread to all 50 states
and the CDC declared a public health
emergency
in July 2022 the World Health
Organization also declared monkeypox a
global pandemic
here are some images of monkey pox
symptoms as you can see some headaches
swollen lymph nodes you can see some POC
what they call pox pustules around on
his patient's hand
um it also it is spread through close
contact so either through exposure to
the pustules through sexual contact or
through any utter droplet form of
contact
as you can see here this is the as of
the end of November this is the current
distribution of monkey box cases in the
United States as you can see there is a
monkey pox case every single one of the
50 United States and Puerto Rico
moving on to why did I choose this
project
so in the initial outbreak of monkeypox
in the United States there was a limited
testing capability at the local level
and this was mainly due to Regions for
the test machines for the tests were not
widely available testing when it's a
infectious disease emerging infectious
disease It could only be done at a
government public health lab and it's
only 70 of them in the United States
and it um due to due to the low number
of labs in the low number of regions and
testing machines in the first month of a
known monkeypox testing capacity only
2000 tests
um why I was passionate about this
project is because I'm also a public
health major and I worked in the
healthcare field as an EMT
um during the code 19 pandemic
um one of these other articles which I
read looked at um
how in during the initial outbreaks of
code 19 many people were not able to
access tests because the initial
screening criteria was just based solely
on your travel history and not on your
symptoms which we now today is not the
correct way to go about testing since
Community spread has probably already
happening by the time you test your
first positive patient
so moving on to the goals of the project
what I
um hope to accomplish with this project
was
um I hope to I was hoping to utilize
machine learning to help guide providers
to prioritize patients for monkeypox
testing and do that based on a
combination of medical history and
clinical presentation
um so while you may be eligible for code
from for monkey box testing either to
exposure to lifestyle or through
um one or two symptoms that you may have
my goal of the project was mainly for a
provider to be able to look at an
algorithm or a model and be able to
input a patient's symptoms and then to
also input the personal chemistry and
then hopefully come up with a model that
will predict
um the likelihood that the patient may
turn positive when a monkey pucks tests
um this would be especially useful in
the beginning of a pandemic or an
epidemic in the area because this would
allow for
clinicians to efficiently Target testing
and they have limited resources
um and this would be very important
during Public Health Emergency when
um there you can't test everyone but you
had to choose who to test and this would
hopefully guide clear conditions to go
through that difficult decision they had
to make
so the data set I looked at was from a
study that looked that was called the
clinical features and now presentations
of human monkey bugs in central London
Center during 2022 outbreak
so um this study collected PCR samples
it was a retrospective study actually
from approximately 30 000 patients who
presented to a hospital with a possible
monkey pox infection
the data set is actually pulled from
kaggle and has already cured and
annotated before I had gotten to it so
the final exclusion number for the
patients was around sorry inclusion
number rather was around 25 000 patients
um so included the clinical station
along as the past medical history as
long as the PCR test that's paired
matches it after day taking a test
so moving on to what a sample part of
the data looks like
so here's the first few rows of the data
set you can see here there's
de-identified data with the patient IDs
unfortunately this data set didn't have
any demographic information so I was
unable to do any analysis on the
demographic part of the patients so you
can see here this is also a
um for it has around 10 features and 25
000 objects so the features included
systemic illness which is like illness
or non-specific to anyone illness such
as fever or swollen lymph nodes they're
just indicative of it infection and then
it goes on to the next few Hallmark
symptoms of monkey pox versus regular
pain sore throat penile edema oral
lesions solitary lesions
um HIV infection
swollen tonsils a history of sexual
transplant infections and then lastly is
the target variable that I'm going to be
looking at in my machine learning
algorithm which is the monkey box status
and it's a negative positive based on if
they end up being negative positive in
the PCR test so outside of systemic
illness everything else was a binary
um
result it was a true or false so in
order to make
um
life easier and be able to Wrangle this
data set better I converted this
category data to numerical data by using
label encoders so I assigned zero to a
false in one to a true and then I did a
one hot button to
to convert the category data for
systemic illness to numerical since
there's more than one answer there
um moving on I did some exploded data
analysis
um and I looked at some of the initial
results I got from just looking at the
data and the distribution of the data
um as you can see here there's it's
definitely more amount of positives and
negatives in this data set as well as
you can see here some breakdowns from
some of the symptoms
um there's slightly more
negative uh patients who took patients
such as negative
um who have who do not have STIs you can
see in systemic illness that there's a
lower incidence of
so a higher incidence of
swallow lymph nodes or a fever in
patients who are positive monkey pox so
this is just a sample of some of the
um of my notebook of where it has a
breakdown of each of the symptoms and
their distribution amongst positive and
negative monkey pox patients
um and then hopefully this model will be
able to predict the patient based on
these symptoms so moving on to some of
the methods that I use for this um to
create this uh
model weather so first I did exploratory
data analysis and processing data so
like I said before you saw me talk about
the first few lines of data where I got
around a large uh I think it's a 25
megabyte um raw text file of the
patient's data it was already curated
which means that it already had two
false on it it already had all the
students there there's no invalidated
there's no missing data so there's
nothing to do with changing the data in
that sense
um some explosion that I I did was I
made um
large bar charts and histograms for
um each of the
the 10 variables that were sorry 10
features that were
used in this model
and then the processing data part was
just me converting the category data to
numerical data
uh moving on the clustering data I use
two different cluster methods to attempt
cluster the data so I use K means
hierarchical clustering and Birch
clustering none of them yielded any
significant results
so then moving on I decided to do a
ridge regression model on this on this
um data set the rich regression model
was the first one since it was a case
very similar to logistical
um regression plot it seemed like the
first step to do for this um for the for
the plot
um and the original question allowed for
me to normalize the data
um that that yielded around a 68
um accuracy rating for that model so it
wasn't that great so that I moved on to
going to random Forest which is able to
handle large and complex data sets it's
also good at handling categorical data
as well
um we ran up for us I got around 70 with
a 30 accuracy rating when it's um hello
20 of the data was used as a training
set
um and 70 wasn't that significantly
better than individual regression so I
tried to use Lizzy protect which used to
look at multiple different models
um and the models accuracy ratings range
foam around 66 to around 70 as well
um so it was it was pretty difficult
trying to get the model to above 70
accuracy rating
um as you can see here
these are some of the results from the
different models
um the top left I believe is the Rich
regression the bottom left was the
random forest and then the right side
was the lazy predict results as you can
see here
um most of the lazy bird deck results
did not break
um the 65 or 70 percent mark
so um
30 while it is a lower
um activating than I would like I think
that the data was not too diverse in
terms of
um the demographics in terms of how it
was distributed amongst different um
groups as well it was not very diverse
so it was hard for the model to be made
more accurately
so that's why it would make it may be
better to use it on a more diverse
patient population and then maybe use a
different data set to cross-validate
against patient populations as well
um 70 well it may not be the greatest
for a model it is
um better than I would say nothing
during a Public Health crisis because
any way you can make targeting testing
efficient during a Public Health crisis
that means that you're able to mitigate
an outbreak and by testing and
quarantine a patient earlier on than
later
um
one way that I would also go on with
some of this go on with um
the models would probably try to use a
tree plot I was unable to do it with
this round
um simply because I saw how the code did
not work
um but using tree plot and maybe
additional clustering to try to see if
there's any concurrence with symptoms in
this um
in this data set and then it may be
useful to look if if some symptoms are
clustered together and how that may
affect a positive negative result for
monkey pox
um another study that I was looking at
looked at a actually a code study
um the code study what he did was they
used an app that
um was a symptom tracker and a simple
tracker would track symptoms of a
patient and then depending severity
symptoms and the type of symptoms the
Asian machine learning algorithm to
um predict when this patient may turn
positive and they attracted amount of
days so I think tracking the amount of
days since onset of symptoms may be a
very useful data data set I'm sorry a
piece of data that could be used through
this data set to enhance the model
accuracy
um another study that was looked at was
using machine learning methods to create
an algorithm for
um to evaluate images of monkey pox
lesions as you can see here this was
taken from one of the studies where a
patient downloads the app and they're
concerned for lesion evidently a lot of
patients who are wearing a risk
risk demographic for this disease were
usually very worried about any little
skid abdom amount they had
so they had a large influx of patients
who want to get tested because of these
small rallies which could be anything
from a pimple to chickenpox to something
else so what the app did was it would it
would take a picture a patient should
take a picture of their lesion on their
phone they uploaded to that portal and
then the Deep learning server would um
do machine learning algorithms and
neural Nets to try to
identify if that lesion is possibly
monkey pox or not so and then it would
score it based on
um what the machine learning algorithm
said and I would recommend or not
recommend a patient to go to see
hospital to confirm a diagnosis or to
get tested for further
um
treatment
so I think these two studies highlight
what machine learning can bring to
um infectious disease especially when
um we're seeing this more and more often
it's important to be able to utilize
these these methods to mitigate
outbreaks early on
and that was my presentation and here
are my references
thank you